[Music]
people think of classical dancers as
like these perfect
soft fairy tale characters and i've been
asked before
wouldn't you want to be perfect why
would i keep doing this if i were
perfect at it would be so boring
having been a professional for almost 20
years
i want to bring ballet to more people
every human being should experience
dance in some way at some point
in this master class you will learn a
simple way
of approaching the ballet technique as
well as all that it takes to accept
who you are and embrace who you want to
be
you're really in such a vulnerable state
when you're with someone on stage and
you're experiencing what you are and
then you also have to be
so free
the number one thing is absolutely trust
i didn't start ballet until i was 13.
i experienced a lot of hardships from a
young age
speaking was terrifying and so to find
this
language through movement was like oh
this has been the missing link my whole
13 years of living
it wasn't until dance came into my life
that it made me confident
focus on your placement principles as
you move to attitude on releve they will
help keep you from pitching your upper
body forward
[Music]
so i rotate in and then when it comes to
working with a choreographer come in
with the approach
of being a blank canvas you're there to
be molded
i went through a really difficult time
where i started to
believe people's words that i wasn't
right i wasn't good enough
it was a way of saying you don't have
the right skin color for
dance i could have walked away but i
took it as fuel
own your power and your voice do not let
other people's words define you
i'm misty copeland and this is my master
class
[Music]
you